foreign  built over a thousand years  it was meant to be a tower of dreams  but for a thousand more it was seen  as a tower of ruin  [Music]  persevering from fire and ice  and the coldest of winds  eventually the tower became a symbol  of unrelenting ambition  that tower's name is babylon  does the savior of neo-babylon stand  among us  let's find out without further ado  [Music]  if i'm to die then i'll die for hope  for what little hope there may be  [Music]  seen through the veil at last have you  [Music]  we're all prisoners of our subjective  reality  believe only what you see and you like  to end up  seeing only what you believe  [Applause]  above the tower will fall  like this one now before you  now begins its tale of both hope  and despair  join the closed beta for babylon's fall